oh yeah no waiting today or a half a day
to get this video why cuz I was actually
still awake when this trailer drop
didn't know it was dropping why was I I
should really do a review of that game
haven't do we have a new trailer for
Deadpool 2 versus more what but you
would think the Deadpool trailer would
have powerful usage of the f-word not
since George Carlin or at least Rocco
from Boondock Saints have I seen someone
so colorfully craft of the f-word so
much dog hair on my microphone just a
bit as cable shows up from you know the
future is like I'm gonna kill that kid
who's the kid don't know who the kid is
he looks like pyro I mean he doesn't
look like pyro but he has fire powers so
well but I don't know maybe it's not
actually if you look at it's only the
implication of fire powers all we know
is his hands are glowing when cars are
on fire around him maybe that's what his
power is maybe his power is ooh my hands
glow when cars are burning it's like a
spidey sense there's danger I don't know
trailer [ __ ] has lied to me too many
times in the past everybody's names Bob
but if they call them Jon's totally pyro
yep cable comes from the future to kill
the kids up bring on the terminator
jokes actually be Terminator 2 you want
to be accurate so I guess Deadpool has
to stop him he forms a group of x-men
called x-force which is why at 6:00 a.m.
Pacific time I heard millions of voices
screaming out in fanboy Glee so he gets
x-force together who are the x-men in
this trail I don't know I'm not gonna
lie unless it's those guys I'm gonna be
drawing names out of a hat watches those
guys one thing I do want to know is that
[ __ ] Pennywise this is a guy razz
bill scars good that if that's not it is
it's gotta be looks just like him I
checked design DB it's not listed so
maybe it's not got some solid doubts now
that his IMDB does not list him in this
movie even if it's not that is totally
Mario glad to see they're bringing some
flower power to the fight yeah we have a
smile for that handgun not like a
handgun I mean handgun I smile and yes
it's true over 15 years after Firefly
marina still looks like that
I call her marina because we're pals for
not shows know what I love about this is
among all the action in the jokes this
trailer takes an opportunity to address
an absurdity in marketing that part
right there I die laughs and why because
that moment in trailers were says from
the studio that brought you act scenes
precisely
jack-shit doesn't mean anything from the
studios so most dandy studios make
greatness and made dog chef New Line
Cinema's when the Lord of the Rings was
coming out could have been like from the
studio that brought you Mortal Kombat
annihilation tracks man well I think I'm
calling [ __ ] on is the fact that
Deadpool is running from these guys what
20 [ __ ] are running after him with
bats and he's hauling ass he's taking on
words I don't know I don't know why he's
running maybe it's actually to start off
the trailer it'd actually be funny if he
jumps into the cab dope hinders peels
away he's like sorry about that dope and
ER I had to run from them to start off
the trailer that won't happen
you know trailer also addresses more
absurdity because it's true gluten
doesn't what does that do gluten might
do stuff to some people but not the
human race isn't gonna die from it but I
leave this trailer with the real
questions in mind is this video gonna
get a copyright flag like my Pacific Rim
uprising reveal different studio who
knows but I use trailer footage we'll
see in the end I'm looking forward to
Deadpool 2 comes out in my birthday
month so yeah I feel like you know
there's a kindred spirit there will it
capture the magic of the first Deadpool
I'm not expecting it - anytime something
unexpectedly impresses me so much like
the first death I mean I expected
Deadpool to be good but they so stuck
that landing I'm not expecting it twice
if I'm entertained fantastic if it's as
good as the first movie - the new
Deadpool 2 trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]